so I think I can break my own rules
today because there's uh some ground
we've missed we're going back a day with
a lot of uh you know on Wednesdays when
we when we respond to people that are
asking for advice for things and so I'm
looking over that there's some good
questions here and so we're going to do
that today instead this is from Jody hi
Matt all thanks to you and the rest of
daily wire crew I'm writing to you as a
former blue-haired feminist who has been
saved from leftism I'm now 30 years old
and I wasted my 20s trying to find a
career sleeping around and doing the
feminist things now more than anything I
want to settle down and have a big
family as I've been dating there have
been several Conservative Christian men
who have great potential but have one
downfall owning a Pit Bull is it shallow
of me to not want to date a guy who has
a pit I've now known of two attacks one
where they almost had to shoot the dog
in front of children because it wouldn't
let go I don't feel comfortable or safe
raising a family around a pit or being
around one myself it feels so dumb
saying that but I also feel like it's a
valid concern is this something that I
am being too stubborn about and should
be willing to budge on or find a
compromise I absolutely would not raise
kids around a pitbull wouldn't do it not
worth the risk okay anytime you have a
pet anytime you have a pet anytime you
have a dog and any kind of dog there's
always a Chance the dog could bite they
talk about percentages what's the
percentage chance the chance is much too
high
that this dog will attack the child and
then the other problem too it's not just
about
will the dog bite the child if the dog
snaps or gets angry or whatever wakes up
on the wrong side of the bed one morning
what is that going to actually mean
how's the dog going to respond to that
like if a golden retriever bites you
it'll hurt can be painful maybe you need
snitches but you don't very often hear
about Golden Retrievers mauling people
to death that's what pimples if they
decide to attack you they will try to
kill you so you're sort of like trusting
this dog to not do that and uh that's
not trust I would have so something
you're not taking serious enough is that
you are you are taking it seriously and
so I don't think you're being too
stubborn and I do think it's a valid
concern I don't I don't think it's silly
at all if this works out and I marry
this man I want to have kids I'm not
gonna have kids with a pit bull now I'm
just not going through this I only have
to you have to toss this guy to the side
right away but it is something to bring
up you say I think this is I think this
is really going in a great Direction I
you know I really like you all these
kind of things talk to them about it but
but then also say I don't want to be
around the pit bull I can't imagine ever
raising kids around a pit bull and let
them let them decide what's the most
important to them we should obviously
kill all the pitbulls right this is also
something that um maybe men should keep
in mind you want to make yourself as
desirable as possible
um you want to give yourself the best
chance possible is it worth it having a
pit bull around that's gonna it's gonna
that could literally scare very high
quality women away these would be great
women who just everything about them is
great they don't want to be around
Pitbull nothing wrong with that it's a
reasonable concern so you want to do you
want to scare those people is it worth
it to have the pit bull or do you want
to just go get a golden retriever
instead you know you've heard me talk
about how important it is to have a VPN
to protect your online privacy but
choosing a VPN you trust is equally as
important I like to do my research on my
sponsors and I only recommend Brands to
my listeners that I believe in to
actually stop people from monitoring
your online activity you need to do what
I do and use expressvpn think about all
the times you've used Wi-Fi at a coffee
shop Hotel even a friend's house without
expressvpn every site you visit can be
logged by the Admin of that Network
that's still true even when you're in
incognito mode especiallypn is an app
that encrypts all of your network data
and reroutes it through a network of
secure servers so that your private
online activity stays private expressvpn
works on all your devices it's super
easy to use the app has one button you
tap it to connect and your browsing
activity is secure stop letting
strangers invade your online privacy
protect yourself at expressvpn.com
walshyt use my Link at expressvpn.com
walshyt to get a free extra months free
that's exp
rssvpn.com Walsh YT Chris says Dear Matt
my wife and I have uh have an
eight-year-old son he's an only child
and was homeschooled but to the age of
seven my wife and I signed him for MMA
soccer skating and t-ball to help
socialize them this year we enrolled him
into a Christian School he's having a
hard time adapting I constantly hear how
nice my son is or that he's too nice
from teachers and coaches I'm proud of
my son is a kind respectful and generous
kid however it hurts my heart to see him
struggling to make friends I'm torn
because I like that he's independent but
I don't want him to be a loner can a
child be too nice and should parents be
responsible for toughening up their
children what are they trying to say is
he allowing himself to get pushed around
you know it's easy getting bullied a lot
not and he's not able to stand up for
himself well that's something you ought
to work with him on but um I would never
say that for an eight-year-old child
we should see it as a problem that
they're nice no I certainly don't think
that you have to worry that an
eight-year-old child is too nice and too
respectful put some respect on my name
or maybe put it this way if that's the
problem that you have with a kid if
that's your biggest problem is your
child is too respectful and nice then uh
you're in a really great spot that's uh
that is a that's a great problem to have
very often especially these days the
problem goes in the other direction
oh as far as him not making friends the
way the way that you you would like I
also wouldn't worry about that I'm
biased a little bit because my old son's
nine years old and
um it's kind of a similar sort of
situation in that he's very outgoing kid
um you know he loves playing with other
kids we haven't evolved in activities
and he's really he's very athletic and
creative and all that but he's also
extremely independent he can go up to
the woods for four hours and by himself
and just work on building a fortune and
he loves doing that so he doesn't make
friends as easily as some kids do and I
know that there are parents who uh see
that with certain kids they're very
independent they can entertain
themselves easily and you start to see
it as a problem and you worry Oh They'll
be friendless their whole life I don't
see it that way you know I I think that
um the kid are eight to nine years old
it's still really young nothing's set in
stone yeah you want to put them in
situations where they can meet other
kids
and you push them a little bit to
socialize but I wouldn't go too far with
that
there's nothing wrong with uh with being
independent and again being able to
entertain yourself as a child is a
really important skill to have a lot of
kids don't have that these are
positive qualities in your child that
maybe presents some challenges but it's
not worth trying to kind of mitigate
those positive qualities
I would just kind of let it play out all
right finally from Anonymous says yeah
all that about marriage is well and good
and your head is no doubt in the right
place man but you offer no actionable
Solutions other than throwing ourselves
into the thing that you just cancel
I suggest that you uh never get married
in the system and You Instead try your
best to sincerely get married with
regard for being seen by God only
this argument obviously boils down to
whether or not this country is going to
hell sooner rather than later us despise
gen Z conservatives are trying to tell
you that it's sooner and in light of
that we will need a little bit more
advice I find it hard to believe that
you don't see that especially with the
brain dead comments you've brought up on
the show so far it seems you're trying
to avoid this and it does scare me a
little to see you shill for America on
this particular topic chill for America
so that you you don't want me to be
concerned about the country that's you
see that as a negative am I Shilling for
America
uh
I I I don't think Shilling would be the
word I would use maybe advocating I'm
advocating for the future of the country
I'm not advocating for the government or
for the regime that controls our country
but I am advocating for the country yes
I love the country
um and I I want to see the country have
a future it's not going to have a future
if people don't get married and start
families okay everything falls apart and
is destroyed in that case and nobody
benefits from that you cannot have a
country you cannot have a civilization
where you where where young people are
not getting married and having families
you cut that out and it is the death of
civilization is what it is and my
position is that that would be bad and I
don't want civilization to die and if
we're just going to embrace that and
accept it then what are we even talking
about like what's the point of anything
why bother why are you watching this
show if you if you're willing to just
give up on civilization I understand
what the problem is I understand how
severe they are but I want to fight to
save civilization not simply give up on
again if we're going to do that then
there's no point in any of us talking
about any of this just give up go home
and wait for it to All Fall Apart and
you can do that and some people have
done that but but don't tell me that
that's the respectable app certainly
don't tell me it's the masculine manly
uh uh you know response uttering
complete surrender being passive is that
is that what being a man is now no the
problems in the system with marriage
I've talked about that extensively and I
have and I have advocated what many of
those Solutions are including for
example
getting rid of no fault divorce
um incentivizing people to get married
and stay married
um strengthening that marriage covenant
as much as we can certainly reforming a
lot of the the alimony laws and so forth
that have that put man at a severe
disadvantage but it's just a question of
yeah those are long-term goals those are
systemic changes that were advocating
forward fighting for promoting
but what are you gonna do in the
meantime
what is society going to do
are you are you just going to give up
completely
you're consign yourself to the death of
your own bloodline that is not a
strategy for dealing with the problem
that is a refusal to deal with it that
is surrender and so if what you're
really saying is we should surrender
then fine but I I strongly disagree with
you that's my pep talk and we'll do it
that'll do it for us today we'll talk to
you tomorrow on Friday have a great day
[Music]